il est à peine 7 heures carlos leitao
maintenant député d'opposition est en
route vers l'assemblée nationale là je
prenne le même chemin
comprenez habitué à la voiture de
fonction et au personnel du cabinet il a
dû apprendre ces dernières semaines à se
débrouiller seul merci
non excusez moi je n'en sais pas plus
que ce soit pour naviguer dans les
méandres de l'assemblée nationale ou
pour gérer son avocat alors là je vais
au bureau déposer mes choses et puis
vers décembre tout d'abord monsieur
entre collègues
comment ça va très bien au delà de la
logistique carlos leitao a surtout un
tout nouveau rôle à apprendre pendant
quatre ans
on s'était préparé à répondre aux
questions la maintenance et c'est le
contraire là on pose la question donc on
sait exactement qu'est ce que qu'est-ce
qu'on va dire au principal je reconnais
le député de roberval oui je le ministre
qui selon les déçus de voir mise à jour
de notre
[Musique]
l'arabe
voici mon niveau bureau le défi est tout
aussi grand pour chantal soucy tout mais
moi je sais même pas qui est ce que dans
les bois par les députés qui en est à
son second mandat de la deuxième
opposition à la vice-présidence public
saura faire ça fait partie des nouveaux
défis que j'ai a relevé le rôle it
complexes et exigeants et requiert une
fine connaissance de la procédure
parlementaire
les règlements de l'assemblée nationale
l'organisation pileux les
fonctionnements nerveuse
non je dirais que je suis très
enthousiaste mme fébrile l'uci alors
j'ai hâte à demain
elle dispose ce soir de quelques minutes
pour se familiariser avec son nouvel
environnement de travail
c'est particulier mais c'est un bonifié
pas chers collègues
c'est un honneur pour moi de m'adresser
à vous pour la première fois à titre de
vice-présidente de l'assemblée nationale
la roue tourne sur la colline
parlementaire
certains gagnent en influence d'autres
en perdent
l'affluence on va là l'exercer
dans les commissions parlementaires
quand tu auras des projets de loi qui
sont déposés par le gouvernement
mais si les responsabilités change le
mandat fondamental demeure le même sens
me donnera un peu plus de temps les
quatre prochaines années d'être plus
présent dans ma circonscription
j'ai toujours priorisé mais cette
conscription avant la partisanerie que
j'avoue que ça m'a amené des résultats
aussi pour ma circonscription
ici ou là vallée radio canada québec